foreign
T is with us in Provo Utah hi Brett
welcome to the Ramsay show
oh thanks Dave thanks for having me on
sure what's up
uh so me and my family we have been
renting for the last year while paying
off student loans uh we paid off 115 000
of student loans it's awesome yeah
thank you
um yeah so we're at a point now where
we're looking uh to save up for a down
payment on a house
um and the house we would be looking to
buy it would take us about three years
to to get a down payment for that house
but we're wondering if maybe it might
just be smarter to wait another three
years so a total of six years to pay for
a house in cash
how much of a down payment are you doing
in three years fifty percent
yeah it's pretty much close to that yeah
houses are pretty how did you determine
fifty percent as a down payment
uh just for the house we were looking at
for no I'm saying 100 000 and you you
said you can do 50 percent
of the house price in three years right
yes
four hundred thousand
uh three yeah I guess 350 is what I was
looking at yeah okay and what do you
make
uh 260. way to go good for you how old
are you guys
uh I'm 32 and my wife is 29. okay well
this is one of the uh maybe the only
answer
that I ever give here on the air that is
um
not what I would do
but what is okay to do okay what I do
the way I live my life for the last 30
plus years now since I went broke is I
don't borrow money
period for anything
ever
and so I have to
figure out a way to cash flow it because
there is nothing that I want badly
enough or that I'm scared enough of to
go in debt for it I have been there done
that I didn't like the T-shirt I'm not
doing it any more okay I truly do
believe that the Bible is telling the
truth that the borrower is slave to the
lender and I truly don't borrow money
and I do believe that that is the
shortest path
to wealth
by the way okay uh the the starting few
years is rough
but the the ending years are amazing
so uh uh uh now having said all of that
then it's the only advice we give here
on the air that I don't personally
follow and that is if you take out a
mortgage with a good strong down payment
50 is more than a good strong a good
strong down payment would be 10 or 15 or
something like that 20 would avoid PMI
that's good and your payment on a
15-year fix is no more than a fourth of
your take-home pay if you did that in
your case
you could then pay that house off within
six years
right right and if you could pay cash
for it in six years you could pay it off
in six years and obviously anyone who
pays their home off in six years is way
weird compared to the culture
so you're you're weird no matter where
we are on the Spectrum yeah and you're
and you're heading in the in the you
know your your face is under the column
of smart people no matter what we do on
this spectrum that's right so either one
of those is fine so it's just a matter
of
some would call me a legalist some would
call me a purist uh someone would just
call me not a hypocrite but um but that
I don't borrow so you can do either by
Ramsey guidelines anywhere in between
those two things and be there so you
could put down 50 you could put down 80
you could put down 20 on a 15-year fix
where the payment's no more than a
fourth year take on pay and it wouldn't
be in this case and then turn a paid off
as fast as you can
all of that is within our guidelines
because we know that that's going to
lead you to wealth Brett how old are you
what do you do for a living
so I'm a nurse anesthetist ah good very
good you're killing it man so yeah that
was where I was kind of having the the
question between the two just because is
it is there any measure on if it's
harder for kids to move when they're
older that was kind of what we were
going between two I mean I wouldn't want
to wait I wouldn't want to move in high
school if that's what you're asking I
think that kids are very resilient I
think that by the time they you know
once they put down Roots if you get into
those high school years it can be a
little bit tough but I mean you can
recover from anything but yeah when
they're how you have you've got kids now
how
so the oldest is seven so seven five and
three seven they're all right she would
be
13 you know if we waited the full six
years to to pay well that's also
assuming you get absolutely no increases
in income right
right yeah yeah I yeah true that's a
good point which is weird because when I
start saving towards something that I
want really bad what I'll do is work my
butt off yeah and my income goes up and
you know I'm able to just attack it and
so my guess is that it won't take you as
long as the math on a straight line
without any increases in Pay says okay
that you should have because your
intensity will go up and your income
will probably go up both during this
time so it'll probably be four or five
years but same thing's true of paying
the house off
yeah yeah if you bought it and we're
living in it so uh we're not going to
yell at you for either one
um uh uh I just love the options that
you're looking at I love that you're
calling in here talking about 50 down or
100 down that's a wonderful quandary to
be in you've got options you've got your
head in the right place that's for sure
and so again I
truly do believe these principles and so
I truly believe that if I live them I'm
going to be the safest
in the event of a pandemic I'm sitting
in a building that's worth
I don't know what's this thing worth now
three four hundred three four hundred
million dollars and it's paid for and
it's paid for and so nobody I didn't
have to worry during the pandemic that
we could make the payments here yeah
okay is that allows this bald head to
lay on a pillow and sleep
you know it just is a different world